[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى
360 من العربيه كالعاده نبدا بابرز
العناوين
ج
عند
بلاطه طريق زمنيه بروسيا يتحدث عن ارض
صلبه مع ايران ويطالب بما حذر الدول
الغربيه من نفاده الوقت
بعد تقارير عن تعاون عسكري مفتوح مع
اسرائيل ايران تنبه اذربيجان وتسترضيها في
ملف الاعتداء على سفارتها
عكس سخونه المعارك بايدن طلب من دول
البلطيق التهدئه مع روسيا واكاب تفضل حربا
اطول عن تسويه سيئه
لدينا ايضا
[موسيقى]
طاوله الست التركيه تختار كليتشار اوغلو
لمنافسه اردوغان والاخير يتهمها بالتحريض
وعرقله النمو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الفرصه مواتيه للخروج من الحلقه
المفرغه في الملف النووي الايراني كان هذا
راي مدير عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفع البروسلي بعدما اعلن ان ايران
وافقت على السماح بمزيد من تدابير
المراقبه والتحقق من انشطتها النوويه لكن
حين الحديث عن الخارطه الزمنيه لكل هذا
فلا توجد خارطه بحسب كروسي رغم ان
التحذيرات لا تنقطع عن اي ايران ماضيه في
برنامجها النووي وتقترب اكثر فاكثر من
الجاهزيه لانتاج سلاح النووي
وفقا لسياسات الدوليه والسياسه بشكل عام
فعندما تتحدث مع صناع القرار فهذا يعني
شيئا مهما واحتراما للنتائج الى جانب ذلك
عندما تتطلع للتصريحات ببنودها الثلاث نرى
تطورا في جميع الجوانب من بينها الصور
والامر يعني ان المفتشين سيقومون بعملهم
بشكل يومي نرى ايضا التزاما كاملا فيما
يخص الرقابه التقنيه الفريق الفني سيسافر
الى ايران قريبا جدا وسيبدا العمل اعتقد
انها فرصه جيده للجميع لكنني لا استطيع
ضمانها انها ليست وعدا بل اتفاقيه صلبه
وفي النهايه اود ان اؤدي عملي
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه قال ان التحدث مع صناع القرار في
ايران يعني الكثيره لتسهيل عمل فرق
التفتيش مشيرا الى ان المفتشين
سيبقون بعملهم بشكل يومي
هناك عدد من القرارات لوكاله الطاقه
الذريه واخرى دوليه تتحدث عن عدم السماح
باستهداف اي مواقع نوويه وان الامر يعد
غير قانوني وخرقا للقوانين الدوليه لذا لم
اتطرق لاي شيء غير عادي او غير معروف
راغده اهلا بك معنا لا خارطه الطريق هذا
ما قاله
او لا ايضا لا خارطه زمنيه بالنسبه
لجراسي هل اثير هذا الموضوع في الكواليس
هل استطعنا ان نعلم ما هي حيثيات هذا
التصريح
اهلا بك يا ميسون يعني من دون شك هناك بعض
التخوف لدى الدول الغربيه تحديد تكون يعني
هذه الوعود التي حصل عليها غروستي والتي
يبدو من انه واثق بانها ثابته هذه المره
يعني وليست وعود كما السابق قد تكون يعني
مجرد يعني محاوله جديده من ايران لتجنب
مشروع قرار جديد ضدها او قرار جديد ضدها
داخل مجلس المحافظين لانه اعتدنا يعني قبل
كل اجتماع لمجلس المحافظين تدعو ايران
بروسلي لزياره طهران يعني يذهب ويعود قبل
يوم بدا هذه الاجتماعات في المرتين
السابقتين لم تكن يعني لزيارته نتائج او
هو ابلغ المجلس بانه لم يتمكن من التوصل
لاي نتائج ملموسه مع طهران ولذلك كان صدور
القرنين ولكن هذه المره يعني كان
التقرير الذي رفعه لمجلس المحافظين مختلف
فيه الكثير من التفاؤل رغم انه هو لا
نفاؤل يسميه واقعيه ورغم انه لا يمكنه ان
يضمن ايه نتائج وليس هناك ايضا يعني اي
اطار زمني ولكن من دون شك الدول الغربيه
تراقب هو دائما قال بانه سيبقيها على
اطلاع حول يعني تقدم هذه المحادثات في
ايران او عدم تقدم هذه المحادثات وبالطبع
يمكن للدول الغربيه ان تعود وتتصرف بامكان
في الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس المحافظين في
الصيف في يونيو او حتى قبل ذلك يعني هي
يمكنها ان تدعوا لاجتماع طارئ في اي وقت
وتبحث يعني ببرنامج ايران النووي اذا ما
شعرت بانه بالفعل هو بدا يشكل خطر حقيقي
وبانه هي لا تتعاون بتاتا مع مجلس مع يعني
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه والمفتشين
هناك ساتابع معك راغده ولكن نذكر بهذا
الخبر العاجل على شاشه العربيه من البيت
الابيض يقول تسميم الفتيات في المدارس في
ايران على انعدام الضمير اذا هذا تصريح من
قبل البيت الابيض على ما يجري من ظاهره
تسمم في المدارس في ايران يقول تسميم
الفتيات في المدارس في ايران هو يدل على
عدم او على انعدام الضمير وقال بانه تسنيم
الطالبات في ايران هو امر غير مقبول
ساتابع معك الان راغده ايضا بالنسبه
للتلاسم الحاصل بين بين اسرائيل والرد على
جروسي يبدو بانه لا يريد ان تستمر هذه او
يستمر هذا التلاسن هل هناك هو تحدث عن ان
القرارات الدوليه تمنع اي ضربه على
المنشات النوويه ولكن هل ايضا في الكواليس
تم الحديث عن هذا الامر هل هناك من ردود
فعل من قبله تجاه هذه التصريحات
الاسرائيليه
بطبيعه الحال يعني هو هو قال بانه هو
دبلوماسي وعمله بان يجد حلول دبلوماسيه
يبقي يبقى متاملا بان تتوصل هذه الحلول
الدبلوماسيه لتخفيف التصعيد لانه قال ايضا
بانه الحل العسكري لن يكون برايه هو الحل
المطلوب وهذا بالفعل ميسوم ما نسمعه يتكرر
من معظم الدبلوماسيين الغربيين عندما
يتحدثون عن ايران عن المفاوضات النوويه
المتوقفه الان حتى يعني كنت اتحدث مع
دبلوماسي الغربي قبل يعني قبل ربما اسبوع
او اسبوعين كان يقول لي بانه الان لا مجال
للعوده للمفاوضات النوويه ولكن مع ذلك
الحل العسكري هو ليس الخيار الجيد بمعنى
انه الدول الدبلوماسيون الغربيون دائما
يبقون يعني الخطوط الدبلوماسيه مفتوحه
وربما يعني هذا واحد من الاسباب التي تدفع
المانيا والدول الاوروبيه لعدم تصنيف ربما
الحرس الثوري الايراني الان على لائحه
الارهاب نسمع دائما بانه ليس قرار سياسي
بعد لاتخاذ هذه الخطوه لانه رغم يعني
الاستياء الشديد من الدول الغربيه لقمع
المحتجين في ايران وايضا لتعاون ايران
العسكري مع روسيا ولتصعيدها في البرنامج
الايراني ولكن يعني هناك هذه هذا الخط
المتبقي معها الذي لا تريد الدول الغربيه
ان تقاطعه كليا الان
بهدف ابقاء هذه المحاولات الدبلوماسيه حيه
شيئا ما رغم صعوبتها الكبيره الان ورغم
اعترافهم بانه يعني هي صعبه الان ولكن
يعني بعد ان ابلغهم بانه حصل ربما على بعض
الامور التي تتعدى الوعود العاديه هما
هناك فرصه الان يعني ودول الغربيه تعتقد
الان بانه يجب منحه هذه الفرصه شكرا لك
راغده باهنا معنا كل هذه التفاصيل
والمعلومات
العربيه كنت معنا
لكن مشاهدينا وسط هذا الحديث عن نفاذ
الوقت لتحجيم ايران نوويا خرجت هارت
بتقرير مفاده ان اجواء اذربيجان مفتوحه
لشن اي هجوم عسكري اسرائيليه على المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه الصحيفه كشفت عن ان
باكو تعهدت لتل ابيب باستخدام مطارات
اذربيجان في حال جنه هجوم اسرائيلي محتمل
ضد مواقع ايران النوويه وذلك في اطار
التعاون العسكري بين اسرائيل
واذربيجان في تقريرها حقيقه ذكرت ان ما لا
يقل عن اثنتين وتسعين طائره شحن اذريه
انطلقت من قاعده
للقوات الجويه الاسرائيليه وهي متوجهه
للعاصمه باكو كما انها محمله باطنان من
المعدات والاجهزه العسكريه
التعاون بين الدولتين فيما يتعلق بالملف
النووي الايراني ليس بجديد فوفقا لمصادر
اجنبيه سمحت اذربيجان لجهاز المخابرات
الاسرائيليه الخارجيه الموساد بفتح ممثليه
له في العاصمه باكو ايضا بنت اسرائيل
مطارا على الاراضي الاداريه ليتم
استخدامها حتى في حال شنت اسرائيل هجوما
عسكريا لتدمير البرنامج النووي الايراني
صحيفه اراد سبق لها ان اشارت الى ان
الموساد الاسرائيلي الذي استولى على وثائق
من الارشيف النووي الايرانيه عام 2018
نقل الوثائق عبر الشاحنتين الى اراضي
اذربيجان ومنها جوا الى اسرائيل
السؤال المطروح الان مشاهدينا ما مدى جدوى
استعمال اراضي اذربيجان في حال حدوث هجوم
اسرائيلي على منشات ايران النوويه اسرائيل
وضعت نصب عينيها كما تقول مصادر
استخباراتيه غربيه استهداف منشات تشمل
خمسه مفاعلات اساسيه نتابعها في هذه
الخريطه مو شهر اصفهانز اراك فوردو ومنشاه
تخزين المواد المشعه في كرج كما ايضا هناك
منشاه بارشين العسكريه بالاضافه الى
العديد من المطارات العسكريه ومنظومات
الدفاع الجوي التي ستشكل الخطر الاكبر على
الطيارين الاسرائيليين لكن قبل الوصول
توجد عده مسارات محتمله للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه لضرب الاهداف الايرانيه منها
مثلا اختراق المجال الجوي العراقي وصولا
الى الاراضي الايرانيه او عبر الاجواء
السوريه التركيه وهما مسارى معقدان لماذا
لوجود
وزن هذه القنبله الكبيره لا تستطيع
الطائرات حمل اكثر من قنبله واحده ما
سيعني حاجه اسرائيل الى اسطول من الطائرات
المقاتله لتنفيذ الهجوم وطائرات اخرى
لمواجهه المضادات الارضيه وفتح الطريق
لتلك التي تحمل القنابل
[موسيقى]
الان سنتحدث عن الجانب السياسي فتصاعد
التوتر بين طهران وباكو في يونيو من العام
الماضي بعدما تحدثت السلطات الايرانيه عن
وجود عسكري اسرائيلي بالقرب من حدود
اذربيجان وايران هو امر نفته حكومه باكو
لاحقا قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبداللهيان ان العلاقات بين البلدين
عادت الى طبيعتها وما لبست العلاقات وان
عادت للتوتر بعد هجوم مسلح مميت على سفاره
اذربيجان في طهران ليعلن مساعد وزير
خارجيه اذربيجان في فبراير الماضي تعليق
النشاط الدبلوماسي للسفاره في ايران بشكل
كامل اليوم طالب المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني دول
الجوار بالانتباه الى ما اسماها حساسيات
ايران في علاقات هذه الدول مع اسرائيل
وشاركااني ايضا خلال مؤتمره الصحفي الى ان
اجراء تحقيق مفصل في الاعتداء على السفاره
الاذربيجانيه مطروح على جدول الاعمال
من باكو ينضم الى روفيس حافظ نائب مدير
وكاله ترند للانباء سيد حافظ اوغلو اهلا
بكم معنا هل هناك اي رد رسميه على هذا
التقرير الذي صدر عنها اراتس والى اي حد
حقيقه هذا التعاون الاسرائيلي الاذربيجاني
وصل الى ما تحدثنا عنه في هذا التقرير
مساء الخير طبعا قبل كل شيء اشكركم
لدعوتكم فما يخص سؤالك يا سيده الكريمه
بانه هل هناك رد رسمي من طرف اذربيجاني
على تصريحات الاسرائيليه او يعني الجريده
الاسرائيليه لا توجد هناك اي تصريح رسمي
من طرف اذربيجاني لكن للاسف الشديد نحن
صار مده طويله يعني تقريبا منذ خمس سنوات
نسمع اخبار او نقره اخبار عن هذه القبيل
من هذه القبيل ان اذربيجان
اعطت اراضيها للقوات الاسرائيليه لكي يضرب
ايران فطبعا هذا ليست لا يوجد هناك اي
دليل رسمي بل هذه التقارير غير رسميه يعني
مطروحه من طرف اسرائيلي لكن ولكن انتم
يعني هل هناك ما يعزز مثلا هذه التقارير
هل من الممكن اذربيجان ان تذهب الى هذا
الحد من التعاون
وتعرف بان هذا الامر خطر ومن الممكن ان
يكلفها اسمنا باهظه اكيد اكيد سيد الكلمات
نحن طبعا لا يعني لا نعترف عفوا يعني لا
نقول لا نخفي علاقتنا مع اسرائيل بل انما
كما تعلم هناك علاقه قويه مع اسرائيل
علاقه استراتيجيه عسكريه استخباراتيه
اقتصاديه والسياسيه وهذا لا تدل على اننا
سنفتح ارادنا لاسرائيل لكي يضرب ايران نحن
كادربيجان اكثر من مره قلنا ان اضربيجان
لا يفتح اراضيها او لا يعطي ارادها لاي
قول قوه عفوا اجن لكي يفتح جبهه جديده على
ايران وهذا كانت تصريحات من سيد الرئيس
اذربيجان وهو عده مره قال انه لا نريد ان
تكون في اذربيجان اي قوه اجنبيه لكي يضرب
ايران لكن ما تخص سؤالك بخصوص انه هل ممكن
تستمر توصل الامر الى هذه الدرجه لا شك في
انه حتى الان لا ندري يعني قد تكون هناك
مشكله في المنطقه يعني من طرف ايران لكن
حتى الان اذربيجان لا يؤتي او لا لم اعطت
اي جزر من ارادها الى القوات الاجنبيه
لكي تكون هناك يعني العمليه العسكريه ضد
الايران في نقطه مهمه اذا ممكن لو تسمحي
اقول انه علينا نكون شويه واقعيين هل
اسرائيل تحتاج الى اذربيجان اراضي
الاذربيجانيه هل اسرائيل اذا كانت هناك
يعني حرب على الايران
ستعرب الايران لوحدها ام ستكون هناك حليف
من الدول العربيه او الغربيه وامريكا اكيد
يعني سيكون هناك حلفاء اسرائيل لكن ما يخص
اذربيجان حتى الان موقفنا ثابت بما يخص
القضيه الايرانيه طب بالنسبه ايضا لموضوع
الاعتداء الذي حصل على السفاره
الاذربيجانيه يبدو اليوم بانه ايران تحاول
ان تستميل
اذربيجان من جديد وتقول بانها فتحت تحقيق
بذلك ما الجديد حول هذه القضيه وكيف
تتعامل اذربيجان تجاه هذا الموضوع خاصه
بعد هذا التصعيد والتوتر الذي حصل بين
الجانبين
طبعا اسف الشديد نحن طبعا
ونعلم ان ايران لديها خبره في يعني تهجير
السفارات الاجنبيه ويعين هناك اكثر من
عشره مرات ومهاجمه السفارات الاجنبيه كانت
هناك الهجوم على القنصليه السعوديه في ما
شاء في قم اذا لا اخطا يعني فعندهم خبره
في هذا الامور لكن لم يتم هناك تحقيق لانه
طرف الايراني لم يعطي لنا فرصه لكي يروا
هناك المحققين الاذربيجانيين لكن لدينا
المعلومه هناك الوثائق المثبته بان هذا
العمل ارهابي موجه مخطط من سلطات
الايرانيه انا اقصد من القوات العسكريه
الايرانيه ومن استخبارات الايرانيه ضد
السفاره اذربيجانيه لا توجد هناك اي امر
جديد في هذا العمل وكما تعلم حاليا
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين بلدين بين
اذربيجان وايران ممكن نقيمها يعني علاقه
يعني وصل الى صفر لا توجد هناك اي علاقه
هل من الممكن اذا قامت بالتحقيقات وارضت
اذربيجان هل يمكن اعتبار انه هذا التحقيق
هو ورقه مهادنه مع اذربيجان لكي تبقيها
الى جانبها ولا تكون اذربيجان علاقتها
متوتره في ايران خاصه في ظل هذه التقرير
الاسرائيليه
في الشديد نحن نعلم ان المشكله يعني ايران
مشكله كبيره فانا لا اقول انني فلا اتكلم
كانني اذربيجاني كل العالم يعرف ان ايران
تدخل الى
اموره يعني الدول الجيران ايران تعتبر
اذربيجان الاسف الشديد انها اذربيجان لها
حديقه خلفيه لكن اذربيجان دوله مستقله ولن
تسمح الى التدخل ايرانيه الى الداخليه نحن
اذا لا ادري يعني هل تعلمون ام لا لان
هناك بعض
الهجوم على السفاره القوات الامن
الازربيجانيه مسكوا كبير من الشباب
الاذربيجانيين التي تضاربوا في القوات
العسكريه الايرانيه فيعني هناك الخطه
ايرانيه كامله لكي يخرب الداخلي الامن
الداخلي في اذربيجان نحن طبعا لا نريد ان
نقرب علاقاتنا مع ايران لكن ايران هي التي
تريد تخطط او تخرب علاقاتها مع ايران ما
اذربيجان ولها يعني اهداف معينه في هذه
المنطقه شكرا لك من باكورد نائب مدير
وكاله تراند للانباء على المشاركه معنا في
والان في مسلسل تسميم الطالبات في ايران
الذي وصفه البيت الابيض قبل قليل بالمخزي
اعتبر المرشد الايراني علي ان قضيه
التصميم جريمه لا تغتفر وطالب السلطات
بملاحقه مرتكبيها وبمعاقبتهم
قضيه تصميم طالبات المدارس قضيه مهمه اذا
تورط بعض الاشخاص في هذه القضيه فهذه
جريمه كبيره وعلى السلطات تتبع مرتكبيها
بجديه ومعرفه اسبابها هذه جريمه لا تغتفر
يجب معاقبه مرتكبي هذه الجريمه بقسوه ولن
يكون هناك عفوا عنهم
[تصفيق]
هذا ودعت مجموعه شبابيه في ايران تطلق على
نفسها شباب احياء طهران الى التظاهر غدا
امام مبنى البرلمان ودوائر التربيه
والتعليم احتجاجا على استمرار الهجمات
الكيماويه على المدارس في جميع انحاء
البلاد وطلب المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات
المعلمين بالسماح لوفد من النقابيين
والسياسيين المستقلين والاطباء والحقوقيين
بالتحقيق في الملفات كما شدد المجلس على
ان حجم المدارس التي تعرضت للهجوم وعدد
المصابات يدلان على ما وصفه بالاعمال
التعسفيه لمنتسبي النظام المتشددين
[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع اذاعه راديو فارده قالت
غزاله شارماهد ابنهد ان اعدام والدها
وشيكون مشيره الى ان برلين بامكانها تحرير
والدها الذي يحمل الجنسيتين الالمانيه
والايرانيه
في العربيه 360 نتابع تقرير اممي يحذر
طالبان تسعى لمحو النساء من الحياه العامه
[موسيقى]
360 من ملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه يبدو
ان خلاف مجموعه فاقنر مع الجيش الروسي لم
ينتهي قائد المجموعه
قال ان ممثله منع من الوصول الى مقر
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه حذر من ان اجبار
افاجنر على تراجع سيدفع الجبهه باكملها
الى الانهيار
[موسيقى]
اذا انسحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار
باكملها فاجنر متراصه ويمكنها سحب الجيش
الاوكراني وتدميره مع عدم السماح لهم
بالتركيز على اجزاء اخرى من خط المواجهه
ايضا نحن نتقدم الى الامام ويجب على
الاخرين اتباعنا باي طريقه لحفظ ماء الوجه
ما يعني اعاده التعلم ويمكننا القيام بذلك
من المهم كسر الصوره النمطيه المقاتلون
يسالونني لماذا التاخير في امدادات
الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو وايضا لماذا
لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر جدد
قبل ذلك كانت فاجنر اعلنت سيطرتها على نحو
40% من مدينه الى ان القوات الروسيه تواصل
قصف اي امدادات يمكن ان تدخل عبر الطريق
السريع الى القوات الاوكرانيه واشارت الى
ان المدينه مطوقه من ثلاث جهات
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه اتفق
مع القاده العسكريين على استمرار عمليات
الدفاع عن باخمه وخلال اجتماع مع كبار
القاده العسكريين بحث توزيع الاسلحه
والمعدات بحسب العمليات على الجبهات
لكن مشاهدينا بعيدا عن الميدان الولايات
المتحده تحاول دفع حلفائها لتخفيف حده
الخطاب المعادي لروسيا وبحسب مصادر تحدثت
لصحيفه
قالت ان الرئيس جو بايدن ضغط خلال زيارته
مؤخرا الى بولندا ضغط على قاده دول
البلطيق لتليين مواقفهم تجاه روسيا وهي
الضغوط التي تسببت بشكوك في دول البلطيق
حول ما اذا كانت واشنطن تعتبر هزيمه روسيا
في الصراع في اوكرانيا هدفا واقعيا
بالتزامن اعرب حلفاء في اوروبا الشرقيه عن
مخاوفهم بسبب تزايد ظهور الافكار التي
تفيد بانه يجب على اوكرانيا ان تستعد
للمفاوضات مع روسيا في مرحله ما لكن على
الجانب العسكري اعلن وزير الدفاع الامريكي
استون ان القوات الامريكيه ستحافظ على
وجودها في دول البلطيق بعد ان تظل ملتزمه
بحريه وسياده هذه الدول وردعي اي تهديد
للامن المشترك واستنقال في مؤتمر صحفي
مشترك مع وزير الدفاع الاستوني هانوف في
العاصمه تالين اننيتو يزيد من امكاناته في
مجال الردع ويزيد من مستوى الدفاع في
الجزء الشرقي من الحلف كما تعزز الولايات
المتحده وجودها على الجانب الشرقي من
الحلف وستحافظ على وجودها المستقر في دول
البلطيق
النيتو يعزز الردع والدفاع في الجناح
الشرقي كما تعمل الولايات المتحده على
تعزيز وجودها في دول البلطيق وسوف نحافظ
على وجود دوري دائم في هذه الدول
نشرت مقالا تحليليا تناولت فيه اخطار اي
تفاوض محتمل بين روسيا واوكرانيا في
المستقبل القريب او حتى البعيد الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان محادثات السلام مع روسيا لا
طائله منها ما لم يتخلى بوتين عن طموحه
لدفع الناتو بعيدا عن اوروبا الشرقيه وبعد
مرور عام على حرب اوكرانيا بدات محركات
الدبلوماسيه تتسارع الصين قرحت خطه لانهاء
الحرب وتركيا قدمت نفسها كوسيط لتنضم
الدولتان الى سلسله طويله من الدول برازيل
اندونيسيا اسرائيل وجنوب افريقيا وغيرها
قالت انه على الرغم من تعهد اداره بايدن
المتكرر بدعم اوكرانيا لاقصى مدى زمني الا
ان واشنطن مقيده بحد معين من الاموال
والمعدات التي يمكن للولايات المتحده
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا وفضلا عن الجوانب
التقنيه توجد تيارات ايضا في الحزبين ان
كان الجمهوري او الديمقرا ترفض تحمل
مسؤوليه حرب لا يروح افقا لنهايتها لكن في
هذه الحرب التسويه السريعه التي ربما تفشل
ستكون اسوا من عدم التسويه بحسب الصحيفه
الامريكيه التي قالت ان اي حل دائم يجب ان
يستوفي عده شروط اذا اردنا ان نتذكر او
نذكر هذه الشروط مثلا ان تقبل روسيا
اوكرانيا كمحاور مباشر على ذات الطاوله
وعلى قدم المساواه لا ان تعتبر اوكرانيا
وكيلا عن الدول الغربيه في هذه الحرب
نوهت الى ان روسيا لم تتعامل مع اوكرانيا
كمحاور شرعي خلال جولات متعدده من
الدبلوماسيه تحديدا في عام 2014 و2015
وبدلا من ذلك اعتبرت حينها روسيا الوضع في
شرق اوكرانيا حربا اهليه داخليه رغم
القتال بين القوات الاوكرانيه والعناصر
المواليه والمدعومه من موسكو هناك شرط اخر
بحسب التقرير هو توصل روسيا واوكرانيا الى
اتفاق بشان التكوين الاقليمي لاوكرانيا
ووحده اراضيها وفي هذا الصدد ذكرت الصحيفه
بمقالات وخطابات للرئيس الروسي منذ عام
2021 حول الوحده التاريخيه بين اوكرانيا
وايضا روسيا
ان الاخفاقات العسكريه الروسيه والدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا ربما يعمقان التزام
بوتين باطاله امد الحرب لكن في ذات الوقت
قد تجد روسيا نفسها في مازق بسبب انفاقها
للموارد في اوكرانيا وقد تتسبب بحسب
الصحيفه باضطرابات سياسيه محليه في مرحله
ما قد تقود الى تهدئه القتال واشارت الى
ان التوصل لحل في اوكرانيا جزء كبير منه
بيد الرئيس الروسي الذي ينبغي ان يراجع
اهدافه الاستراتيجيه بشكل عام
ومحاوله التخلي عن طموحه القاضي باعاده
تشكيل اوروبا وفقا للرؤيه الروسيه
من ابو ظبي ينضم الى عبر الزوم فيتالي
فيتامين دبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه سيد بتالي
اهلا بكم معنا في اي اطار يمكن ان نضع هذه
التصريحات من قبل الرئيس بايدن تجاه دول
البلطيق هل يمكن اعتبارها بانه فتح نافذه
مع روسيا لحل هذه الازمه وايقاف الحرب
مساء الخير يا الكرام
اذا تحدثنا عن اي مفاوضات السلام يعني مع
روسيا فلابد ان نتذكر ان
قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده تم
اعتمادها يعني قبل اسبوعين باصوات 141
دوله والذي يدعو الى الى الانسحاب الفوري
لروسيا من الاراضي الاوكرانيه ومعاقبه
المجرمين واستعاده العداله يستند هذا
القرار على صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه التي
طرحها الرئيس زيلينسكي ومنذ هذه الفتره اي
مبادره واي خطه للسلام من اي دوله يجب ان
تمتثل للقرار المذكور للجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده هذا مهم جدا يعني بالنسبه
طب بالنسبه ايضا
لموضوع المواقف من قبل الرؤساء يعني
الرئيس بايدن منذ اشهر قال لا نسعى الى
تغيير النظام في روسيا ايضا الرئيس ماكرون
قال لا يجب اذلال روسيا هذه المواقف كيف
انتم تقراونها يعني الا تفكرون بان هذه
التصريحات ستكون هي بدايه مثلا لاي حل
دبلوماسي من قبل هذه الدول لانها لا
تستطيع ان تبقي هذا الدعم الى اجل غير
محدد وخاصه دعم العسكري وما يكلفه
نعم ولكن يعني نصيحتي للجميع اتركوا
التصور القديم عن اوكرانيا كدوله التي
تتعرض للضغط او الاجبار للمفاوضات او
الحوار لان اليوم اوكرانيا تضغط وتفرض
الشروط وستحدد اوكرانيا كيف وباي شروط
تنتهي هذه الحرب العدوانيه
لنكون واقعيين اوكرانيا تفرض هذه الشروط
لان هناك دعم غير مسبوق ياتيها من الدول
الغربيه ومن الولايات المتحده ولكن اذا
هذه الدول وصلت لمرحله اصبحت غير قادره
على تثبيتكم بهذه الاسلحه المتقدمه هل
ستستطيعون الصمود
وتضعون هذه الشروط التي تتحدث عنها
عيون ولا نعيشين في الاوهام وهذا الموقف
واكده وشركاءنا الرئيسيون يعني الامارات
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي ونحن
يعني نخلق هذا التاريخ الجديد يعني مع
شركائنا يعني
الذين يعني يقفون الى جانب اوكرانيا نحن
واقعيون وطبعا نحن ندري ان هناك من لا يثق
في انتصار اوكرانيا ولكنني قبل سنه قال
النفس الاشخاص انه غير قادره على مقاومه
انتم مقتنعون بانه الانتصار هو المخرج
الوحيد لهذه الازمه وليس الجلوس على طاوله
مفاوضات
نحن جاهزين للجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
ولكن اهم شيء قبل بدء اي مفاوضات نحن لازم
نوفر انسحاب الفوري للقوات الروسيه من
الاعراض الاوكرانيه لان اللا تصون
اوكرانيا على حقها في استعاده وحده
اراضيها لا يمكن المصومه على
مبدا السلامه الاقليميه يجب على اوكرانيا
والعالم كله ارسال رساله واضحه الى جميع
المعتدين المحتملين مفاوض ان
العضوان سيضمر الدوله المعتادة فقط يعني
دوله المعتاده يعني قبل كل شيء
يتخوف اذا وضع الرئيس بوتين في موقف سيكون
او سيبدو فيه الخاسر من الممكن ان يعني
يستخدم اسلحه نوويه وهذا ما لا تريده اي
دوله في العالم
يعني اليس من الاجدر ان تبدا
بتقديم بعض التنازلات من قبل كل الاطراف
للوصول الى حل وايقاف هذه الحرب حتى لا
نصل الى هذا التصعيد الكبير ونصل من
الممكن لتحريك هذه الاسلحه
نحن نرجو ان لا ينخدع احد بدعوات روسيا
الفارغه وكاذبه لاجراء المفاوضات او
جاهزيه لاي تنازلات لان روسيا تواصل
ارتكاب جرائم الحرب والاباده الجماعيه ضد
الشعب الاوكراني تقصف وتقتل المدنيين ولا
تزال تسعى الى تدمير اوكرانيا كالدوله
بشكل علني على سبيل المثال يعني نشر العدو
الروسي اليوم فيديو باعدام
الجندي الاوكراني الاسير يعني غير مسلح
يعني بعد كلمته الماجد لاوكرانيا وهذا
الدليل واضح على ان هذه الحرب حرب اباده
جماعيه يعني لن ترضوا بان تصل او تنتهي
الازمه بموضوع لغالب ولا مغلوب
قال مسؤولون غربيون للصحيفه البريطانيه ان
روسيا متردده في شراء صواريخ باليستيه من
ايران خشيه اقدام حلفاء اوكرانيا على
تزويد كاف بصواريخها بعيده المدى واكد
المسؤولون ان موسكو قد تغير موقفها بسبب
النقص في حجم ذخائرها الموجهه بدقه فضلا
عن تعثر انتاجها المحلي كما نقلت الصحيفه
عن سفيره واشنطن لدى الناتو جوليان سميث
ان الغربيين يجدون العلاقه الروسيه
الايرانيه مقلقه للغايه وان الحلف سيواصل
ارسال اشارات لايران حول مخاطر دعمها
لروسيا
[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار عاجله تاتي من الحواره مراسل
العربيه يتحدث عن اصابات جراء المواجهات
في بلده حوار بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين نتابع هذه الصور لهذه
الاشتباكات والمواجهات الحاصله في بلده
حواره بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين سنتابع الان يبدو بان هذا
الصور ايضا سنعود ونتابعها مجددا نعود
ونذكر بان هناك اصابات جراء مواجهات بلده
حواره بين الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين
اسرائيليين
وهذه البلده التي واجهت ايضا حصلت فيها
ايضا
مواجهات في الايام الماضيه وايضا كان هناك
تصريح
لوزير الاسرائيلي الذي قال بانه يجب ان
يتم محوها وكان هناك ايضا العديد من
المواقف تجاه هذا التصريح بخ بلده حواره
ساذهب الان الى زميلنا خالد القاسم
ليعطينا تفاصيل ما يجري في الحواره خالد
اليك ما الجديد ماذا يجري
يعني اخر الانباء الوارده بان مستوطنا
اطلق الرصاص على مركبه فيها اربعه
فلسطينيين لم يصب الرصافه احد ولكن اربعه
اصيبوا من تناثر الزجاج
المتكسر
هناك اعتداءات من المستوطنين الان داخل
بلده حواره حيث يقومون براقصات استفزازيه
في شوارع البلده والكون الحجاره على
المركبات الماره ويحددون
السكان
بالطرد والقاتل في هذه الاثناء
ولكن خالد يعني هذه المواجهات ليست جديده
يعني الحواره هي تتصدر المشهد في الايام
الماضيه بخصوص المواجهات بين
المستوطنين والفلسطينيين من بلده حواره
اليس هناك من اي اجراءات متخذه حتى لا
تتكرر هذه المواجهات
يعني
الاجراءات هي التي يجب ان ياخذها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لحمايه المدنيين
الفلسطينيين المستوطنون يدخلون الى وسط
حواره يقومون برقصات وهم بالعشرات يجوبون
شوارع الرئيسيه للبلده
بمكبرات الصوت والصراخ والمناداه والجيش
الاسرائيلي يتواجد لا يمنحهم
الاحتياطات التي قام بها الفلسطينيون هي
احكام اغلاق النوافذ والابواب خشيه من
تكرار حوادث حرق المنازل كما حدث
الاسبوع الماضي ايضا يتحصنون ويشكلون لجان
حراسه لتوعيه الناس عندما يقتحم
المستوطنون المدينه على كل حال لخالد نعود
اليك في حال تطورت ايضا الامور التي طلعنا
على اي جديد شكرا لك حتى الان خالد القاسم
الى شان التركيه الان اتفقت الاحزاب
المعارضه التركيه المعروفه بطوله الست
بالطاوله الست على ترشيح كمال لكلتش دار
اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري للانتخابات
الرئاسه القادمه واعلنت كليتش دار اوغلو
ان احزاب المعارضه اتفقت على هدف العوده
للنظام البرلماني واضاف ان بقيه رؤساء
احزاب الطاوله السداسيه سيكونون نوابا
للرئيس معربا عن ثقته في النجاح
بالانتخابات باتفاق المعارضه واتحادها
من جهته اتهم اردوغان احزاب المعارضه
بتحريض الشعب التركي وتكرار وضع العراقيل
امام النمو والتحول المدني على حد قوله
رومانسيه الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم
حزب الشعب الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتجار
اوغلو يقومون بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا
ووضعوا عراقيل امام عجله النمو والتحول
المدني في الماضي والان يكررون نفس
توجهاتهم
[موسيقى]
افاد تقريرا للمقرر الاموي المعني بحقوق
الانسان في افغانستان ريتشارد بنيت حول
اوضاع النساء في البلاد افادا بان سياسه
طالبان المقصوده والمحسوبه هي تنصر من
حقوق النساء والفتيات ومحوهن من الحياه
العامه وانه لا يمكن لبلد ان يعمل في
الوقت الذي يسجن نصف سكانه البالغين في
المنزل بنتاكد في تقريره على ان دور
الموظفات الافغانيات حاسم في تقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه كما حتى حكومه طالبان
على سرعه رفع الحظر المفروض على العاملات
في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
وكانت منظمه العفو الدوليه طالبت الامم
المتحده بالتصدي الانتهاكات طالبان
المستمره لحقوق الانسان وحريه التعبير
مشيره الى ان طالبان استهدفت ايضا مدافعين
عن حقوق المراه
واكاديميين ونشطاء حقوقيين في الاشهر
الماضيه واحتجزتهم بشكل غير قانوني
[موسيقى]
في العربيه
هاتاي التركيه بعد الزلزال الترجمه
الحرفيه لكلمه مدينه اشباح
[موسيقى]
احتجز جنود اسرائيليون طفلين في منزلهما
وسط مدينه الخليل بعد ان قاموا باغلاق باب
البيت ومنعوا الدخول والخروج منه بذريعه
تامين مسيره للمستوطنين الام التي كانت
خارجه بيتها استنجدت بالجيران الذين
تمكنوا من فتح الباب وتحرير الطفلين عبد
الحفيظ جعوان معه تفاصيل
[موسيقى]
بعد دقائق عادت الام الى المنزل لتجد
ابوابه مقفله بشكل كامل وطفليها يصرخان من
النافذه فاستدعت الجيران وبعض الناشطين
الذين هبوا لتقديم المساعده وخاضوا جدالا
طويلا مع الجنود لاقناعهم بضروره فتح
ابواب المنزل وتحرير الطفلين
تقطن عائله البايض شارع الشهداء وسط مدينه
الخليل وهو من الشوارع المقفله منذ سنوات
طوال ويعيش الاهالي فيه شبه سجن دائم
وتزداد قسوه السجن مع المناسبات والاعياد
التي يخرج فيها المستوطنون للشوارع حيث
قام الجنود باحكام اغلاق بعض البيوت
والمحلات التجاريه بذريعه توفير الامن عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 من الضروري
وجود رشاش تحت سرير كل مواطن التصريح
ولوزير الدفاع الاوكراني اليكزي ريزني
الذي اكد ضروره ادراج ثقافه المهنه
العسكريه في المجتمع حينها بحسب الوزير
سيعلم العدو ان كل اوكرانيا يمكنه ان يسحب
سلاحه من تحت السرير ليقاوم
فيديو اليوم من هاتاي التركي بعد شهر من
الزلزال صوت الصمت هو كل ما يسمع في
المدينه وارياح تلعب بستائر النوافذ
المخطمه ومنازل تبدو كانها تحدث بعضها من
قسوه الوحشه لا ينقص المدينه ظلام الليل
كي تتحول كما في افلام الرعب الى مدينه
اشباح لانها بالفعل باتت مدينه اشباح
اما سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من مصر حين
تغيب الظروف الرجال يملانا الفراغ تدب
الحماسه في العروق ويقمن بمهام لا يقوى
عليها اصلا اغلب الرجال
فتتحول الايادي الناعمه الى اياد شديده
الصلابه تحفر في الصخر كيالين وتالين معه
الحياه لمن حولهن
الى هنا تنتهي
360 ولكن دائما الملفات والاخبار مستمره
على العربيه والان ما اخبار الساعه
والزميل صهيب شرير صهيب ماذا لديك من
ملفات الليله مساء ميسون البدايه ستكون من
التطورات العاجله اذا في بلده حواره جنوب
نابلس اعتداء جديد للمستوطنين هناك يسفر
عن ست اصابات بين الفلسطينيين حتى الان
نقلا عن الهلال الاحمر سنكون مع مراسلنا
من الارض الفلسطينيه بعد قليل